the fbi has released new video from the
assault on the capitol
showing some of the mob's most vicious
attacks on police now what you're
looking at these attackers still have
not
been arrested senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge is
tracking the investigation for us
catherine good morning to you
why are they releasing these videos now
well tony good morning the fbi has
already arrested more than 300 people
but it still needs the public's help
to identify these suspects the attacks
range from this person using their hand
to punch an officer in the face to
others using what could be described
as dangerous weapons like this person
dousing police
with chemical retardants from a fire
extinguisher this individual in the cap
and black striped sweatshirt
used a stick to repeatedly hit officers
if you recognize any of these suspects
you're asked to call the fbi or submit a
tip
online in all 134 officers were wounded
in the violence
after the riot two died by suicide and
officer brian stichnick died from
injuries sustained during the riot
cbs news has also obtained an
intelligence asses assessment stating
that domestic violent extremists like
the ones who attacked on january 6
still remain a persistent and particular
threat to the area
since the riots there's been fencing
surrounding the capital to keep it safe
and this new report could impact how
much longer it stays in place gail
all right catherine thank you very much
for that